foreign
I think one of the most important things
that a Science Education can do is not
to teach people what is known but how to
find out what is known and how to be
critical and how to avoid swallowing uh
the first thing that comes into your
head how to be how to how to be
skeptical how to do statistical
reasoning
I think the what medical scientists now
rather love which is the double-blind
control test is a wonderful example of
the right way to think are you they're
testing one drug whether to see whether
it works they have a drug and you have a
control
and the vitally important thing is when
you give some patients that drug and
some patients that control you the
doctor must not know which patient has
the drug and which patient has the
control that's the point of double
blinding
um not the doctor not the niece not the
nurses administering the drug not the
scientists doing the analysis afterwards
they're allowed to know which patient
had which thing now that's a wonderful
discipline it happens to be a rather
simple discipline that medical
scientists do but it's wonderful to
think about the significance of the
double-blind control trial I'm reading
your book again we've had State
education for quite some time now
everyone is literate so we can all read
the words but we don't seem to be
treated
trained to treat the words to look at it
go oh I wonder
um so we're sort of halfway there
especially at the problem with the
internet where we can all Now read stuff
that has never been through any kind of
gatekeeper until the internet came along
anything that was printed had probably
been through some sort of editorial
control some sort of refereeing some
sort of reviewing and so it wasn't just
everything out there now everything's
out there and one of the problems with
that of course is the the phenomenon of
the closed bubble where people seek out
others who have the same opinion as they
do and it's an echo chamber it's another
word for it an echo chamber in which all
you ever hear is people who agree with
you and that's why we get the phenomenon
of things like flat earthism which is
being revived now because the Flat Earth
will seek each other out
in our ancestral evolutionary past we
might have lived in small villages or
small roving bands we've just met 150
people or so and those were the people
you you knew now you seek out your own
150 people anywhere in the world this is
your bubble this is your Echo chamber of
flat earthers or whatever it might be
and so they reinforce each other you get
the feeling over must be something in
Flat Earth is it because everybody I
talk to seems to believe in it and and
that's what that's what we're up against
now we we've lost Gatekeepers in a way
that's a good thing it's a nice thing
that people are able to
um Express their opinions without it
having to go through an editor on the
other hand it has this downside but
wouldn't it be better if those opinions
Were Somehow rooted in knowledge
of course and and that's what we want to
try to achieve somehow build back
critical thinking so that people say not
just this is what I hear people saying
on the internet but what's the evidence
for it what's the evidence for this what
lies behind it where can I look up the
facts behind it you quote Carl Sagan in
your book and there's a wonderful image
that you evoke which I knew but your
book reminded me that Carl Sagan looks
at a photograph of the solar system
taken I don't know what it was Voyager I
mean Voyager is outside our solar system
now and it looks back at our Earth
and our Earth is one blue pixel
and he says you know everything you ever
loved everything you've ever known is on
that little blue pixel now why does
Vladimir Putin not get up in the morning
and think that why doesn't Boris Johnson
think oh sorry I'll tell lies but that
doesn't help my little blue home why has
it not got through It's a Wonderful
rhetorical piece I I sure most of you
know it probably I mean it's a beautiful
piece of poetic writing I think Carl
Sagan should have got the Nobel Prize
for literature I mean never mind about
science
um it's all it's a beautiful piece of
poetic writing this this image of this
pale blue dot where everything all
histories all Kings dictators
Wars and and things it just all happen
on this tiny little pixel
um Carolyn Porco who's I suppose the
nearest approach we have today to a
female equivalent to have to Carl Sagan
revived the idea she she was in charge
of the um photographing of the Saturn
mission
so she took a photograph of Earth from
Saturn
again a little tiny Dot and invited
everybody on Earth to wave at the same
moment
um to try to bring home rhetorically
this point that Carl Sagan had made a
couple of decades before
now it used to be that what got your
goat was religion how many of you read
The God Delusion
yes now have you mellowed a bit
was Miller
it's a it's a it's a myth an unspeakable
myth that I was ever I I was I was
having a cup of tea with an old friend
yesterday and said I was going to be
talking to you I said oh he's very
controversial I mean
controversially what you said I've never
been controversial you you um you you
may think it's controversial if you're
deeply religious because for centuries
you've been used to the idea that nobody
says anything against religion so even a
very mild cautious tentative statement
against religion
is heard as
violent and controversial and strident
but actually it's very mild I always
have been very mild
and you've I mean one of the best jobs
you ever had in my view was the one
public understanding of science I
thought that was a hugely important job
and you reveled in it didn't you I did
yes now
we we sit on this planet it's hot in
here and it's going to get hotter The
River Why down there I don't know how
spruced up it is how much sewage gets
pushed into it
but it seems to me that we need science
more than ever and we need to be looking
at it as a species together so Richard
could you fix it please the
the science is not in doubt the the
problem is that when you've got the
science the political will to do
something about it now
um as an evolutionist I know that we are
the only species that has ever existed
on this planet that has the gift of
foresight
uh Evolution natural selection doesn't
give a damn about the distant future or
even the middle future it only cares
about the immediate future
so natural selection favors immediate
short-term benefits short-term gain
we are the only species that has the
brain power
to look ahead
decades centuries even years
with the only species that has the has
four sides we can do it and some people
are capable of doing it and there are
voices being raised at the moment
scientific voices political voices that
do look to the Future and can forecast
the consequences of this action or that
action for the species as a whole for
the world as a whole that has never
happened before in a way it's a wonder
it's a blessing
that even one species is capable of
doing that and we are that species
so
don't let
beat up on ourselves too much I mean we
we are unique in having this ability but
unfortunately only some of us have it
and
um the scientists on the whole are
capable of telling you what's going to
happen in the next decades the problem
is to get people as a whole and that I
suppose means via politicians to take
note of it and to take action not for
short-term benefit but for medium and
long-term benefit and that's a difficult
task but it all seems it all seems to be
done on feel I mean the Taliban in
Afghanistan how did they feel I mean
they can't think can they the people in
in America that are taking away all
abortion rights they can't be thinking
and uh and our government here I mean
they're not brains of Britain are they
so what what
the first two you mentioned have have
their respective holy book and so they
know what's True by just reading the
book and and that's absolutely fatal of
course
um the third one you mentioned the
government well the problem with
government so they have to get
re-elected or they want to get to get
reelected and so they have to Pander to
short-term selfishness or they don't get
reelected and that that is a major
problem with democracy and democracy is
wonderful but it does have that drawback
that politicians who get democratically
elected have to Pander to what's going
to get them re-elected in the next
couple of years
so short-term benefit wins out so if you
Pander to Ill thought out Prejudice
you're likely to win
well it'll sort out Prejudice would be
the Taliban and the religious right in
America
I fear the government is only too well
thought out I mean we want to win the
next election and so and so
um the
um what economists call the shadow of
the future is very short
I'm going to change tack or else I'll be
written up in the daily mail
um
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas